because RFK was picking up traction and
I don't I'm not an RFK guy at all but he
should have been allowed to have his
voice he should have that's why he had
to run as independent even though it's
like a raspy voice right I mean I think
that's going to be his downfall because
imagine if he actually end up running
for president can you imagine the memes
vice president Macy
[Laughter]
[Music]
Gray and welcome back everybody to
another extremely cancelable episode of
the careful boy give us your best shot
give uh maybe not well we have today
Matt Kim with us
yay um so recently you posted something
on Instagram that I have no idea
about great Leen something amazing doing
our homework fantastic best interviewer
ever take that Tucker wa you interviewed
him never mind take that Andrew take go
for it so I was in Iowa this weekend for
the Iowa caucus um if you're not
familiar it's Iowa caucus and that's
where the Republicans decide who's going
to be the Presidential nominee uh for
the Republican party so I was over there
for the event and I tried to go to a Ron
Des santis event I applied via their
website for the event um the night
before and the day of after I was at a
trump rally and the day of right after
the Trump rally ended they called me
they called me and they're like hey
we're trying to speak to Matt Kim uh we
want to make sure that you know we're
going to see if you're going to come
because of the weather cuz it was like
-2° and it was snowing and the weather
was horrible we decided we're going to
move the event up from 8:30 7:00 so we
just want to make sure that you're going
to arrive I said yeah of course I'm
going to be there I got your text
message and they're like yeah great like
we just wanted to confirm amazing the
guy I was with who was also applied for
the same event he didn't get the phone
call okay
weird so I show up to the event and I
walk in the door wait so the people you
were with you guys all decided to go
together to the to to see the primary
the Republican primary yeah I just
wanted to go be a part of the Town Hall
like I just wanted to go in like people
[__] on Ronda sandas all the time so I'm
curious like what does he got to say
like what's the event like were you
wearing your mega hat I was not wearing
a mega hat um but I was at the Trump
rally early in the day like I'm all the
way in Iowa I want to see the political
process up close like why not right so I
go to the event and I take maybe two
steps in the door and two steps in the
door security I mean like 64 like like
one of these guys like hey I I got to
talk to you I'm like all right
weird and they're like wait a second
you're like hey can we just talk to you
over here by the door so they pull me
outside into like that little gap
between like the main entrance and and
kind of the secondary entrance and he's
like yeah you know like we we had
problems with someone here before and um
you know the guy kind of looked like you
what so Asian guy in Iowa yeah
like yeah he kind of looked like you so
we just want to make sure he's talking
to me and he goes and he takes a picture
right I'm like all right weird and then
he like he's like talking to me and he
does like this and he's
like you got to go huh I'm like really
like why he's like look it's private
property you got to get out of here I
was like this is [__] like there's
no reason I'm getting kicked out you
guys actually called me to make sure I
was coming do you have like a pass or
anything you can show him or did no no
like he bought a ticket like yeah no it
is free but you have to sign up yeah
they knew I was coming cuz they
literally called me to confirm I was
coming and like look it's private
property you got to go what if there's
another Asian like person that was there
the other day and they were doing some
like smear thing of like protesting and
they're like an Environ Al guy or
whatever and then they're just like [__]
man these [__] Chinese people coming
in here no more ching chong no more
Ching CHS yeah no the night before
that's this was Sunday the night before
on Sunday on Saturday um someone at a
raw descend this town hall had gone up
to stage and presented him with a
participation trophy oh yeah I saw that
yeah oh it's your twin brother and I
mean obviously doesn't look like me at
all no he that guy was like Mexican or
white or something right yeah and that
no one even knows who that guy was it
just happened like organically out of
nowhere and I think they were so
embarrassed by that because I mean r sat
there and accepted it until they
realized oh [__] they're trolling me it
took like a full 30 seconds and like
security like everyone let it happen and
then his wife cases and had to step in
between and like protect him which is
like really
demasculate and that kind of just
happened all over the Internet so I
think they were just really on edge and
I had taken a picture earlier that day
that went online with um a girl named
Laura lomer who is like really well
known within Twitter of being kind of
this in-your-face investigative
journalist and they've kicked her out of
the event the night before and uh the
Dilly meme team which is like known for
making these memes and always like
[__] on the sand campaign so because
there was a picture of me with these two
people oh they thought you were probably
going to do they thought I was going to
be a I see wow because they kicked me
out wait until you see all the spots you
kicked out because you're
[__] oh yeah you thought it was bad
you think you cancel hey is there a good
bubble tea place I can go
instead maybe maybe 10% off yeah I'll
have to fly out of a different
airport yeah so I left the I left the
event after they kicked me out and I
walked next door to a restaurant I'm
like all right it's freezing I haven't
eaten all day I'm just going to go next
door and grab a bite tea before I move
on to whatever else I want to do I walk
into the restaurant and this Chey stops
me like look you're not allowed in here
either I'm like what are you talking
about they followed you or separate
security separate security what the [__]
so everybody just got your [__] photo
like passed around that whole area
they're like this is the same property
and if you're not allowed there you're
you're not allowed in here do all these
people have the [__] curly wire in
their ear I have no idea what's going on
I'm freezing my balls up I just want to
grab a burger and like figure out what
my next move is cuz I didn't not expect
to get kicked out yeah and they're like
you got to
go so I left were your friends there too
or you just by yourself or so the guys
with the Dilly meme team um they they
had no intent on going in because
they're kind of known to the campaign so
what they did and they had no idea I was
getting kicked out cuz we separated I'm
going to go in and they're going to go
eat but you know they ended up hanging
out in front of the Ron de santz tour
bus smoking
cigars and and they're sitting outside
smoking cigars and Ron de Sanz were so
scared to run into these guys in person
that he wouldn't get out of his tour bus
what and he sat in the tour bus and held
up the entire event for 30 minutes wow
while they were outside smoking a cigar
so there's five security guys standing
in front of them and Brendan who kind of
runs their thing over there he's like
look like you know I'm not do anything
right like everyone like there's
security here there's cameras here like
I'm just here like I'm allowed to be
here and they're like oh yes sir they're
still outside he wouldn't he wouldn't
leave the tour bus because he was he was
scared of getting trolled and I'm like
how can you be running for president if
you're scared of a little bit of social
media pressure like you have to be able
to handle this so I thought that was a
really weird like really weird odd thing
so after I get kicked out of this Ronda
santz event there is a guy in a
wheelchair I didn't know him before this
but he had the Dilly meme Team hat on I
guess security didn't notice when he
walked into when he rolled in I'm sorry
he didn't
walk when he rolled into the event the
security saw him in a wheelchair and
they put him in the front row oh nice
because it looks really good on camera
right in front of the media look there's
a guy in a wheelchair here right in the
front row supporting Ron but they didn't
know that he was a supporter of the of
of
to them the enemy wow so he's sitting
there just watching didn't say a word
it's he's like 40 50 years old um he's
just sitting there listening causing no
problem whatsoever he's just sitting up
front and and it's not his fault he's
sitting number one number two it's not
his fault he's up front they put him
there as soon as i k get kicked out
they're like oh [__] there's another guy
so they grabbed his wheelchair and they
removed him and they put him outside oh
who how are you going to take a guy grab
his wheelchair which is like totally
against like the rules of like
handicapped you like your wheelchair is
an extension of yourself so they
separated him or you mean they just
grabbed all grabbed his wheelchair and
they they moved him out yeah no they did
like physically that' be the same thing
as if someone gra just didn't removed
you that's exactly the same at least to
that Community right because that is how
they move yeah that's their legs exactly
and they just grabbed them and again -
20° outside damn just put him outside in
the cold damn damn I hope he was wearing
a sweater 20 bro yeah and they're just
like you got to get out of here and he's
like dude I didn't do anything and he's
like you got to go and it was like the
weirdest experience because on the flip
side you know I was there and once the
Trump campaign found out I was there
they were like hey you want to see
inside like you know people watch you
people trust you like you can come in
and see everything going on in the
campaign and they literally gave me like
this Trump pass to like go behind the
scenes and they're like I I thought when
they gave me a pass to go behind the
scenes of their campaign they would be
like all right here are like some rules
here are some like things you can talk
about things you can't talk about things
you can do you can't do today's video is
brought to you by rocket money now a lot
of you guys slide in our DMS and you'll
be like yo how do you like get more
financially intelligent how do I stop
spending how do I do this well rocket
money is here to save all of us if you
like to go out and spend frivolously and
you need somebody to help you manage
your funds rocket money got you like me
I'll be out there like this month I'm
not going to be spending too much money
on coffee so I'll set myself a budget
and then I go out there and what do I do
I end up spending too much money on
coffee but what if there was something
out there that said uh excuse me you're
over your limit today you should
probably start making coffee at home
rocket money does exactly that for me
you know how many people are like oh my
goodness JK news I'm a doctor and I'm
poor and it's because there's an age-old
saying is not how much money you make
but how much money you spend and that's
why I love rocket money cuz it controls
you're spending all over the place from
managing your subscriptions to how much
you're spending setting budgets are you
spending too much money on your car M
are your savings are you even putting
money away are you dollar cost averaging
yourself paying yourself you can set
those things daily weekly monthly and
every time your girlfriend yell at you
you put $5 away you be a millionaire yep
and I'm pretty sure if you're anyone
like the rest of us you got all these
subscriptions and you don't even know
every month you're paying it well what
if you had something that told you
excuse me you're not even using this
anymore but you keep paying it every
month why you got 12 porn subscriptions
yeah rocket money is a personal finance
app that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscription
monitors your spending and helps lower
your bills as well rocket money has over
5 million users and has helped save its
members an average of
$720 a year with over $500 million in
canceled subscriptions so stop wasting
money on things you don't even use
cancel your unwanted subscriptions by
going to Rocket money.com sloff theer
that's rocket money.com sloffer
rocket
money.com offthe they were like here's a
past have fun and that was it so it's
such a stark contrast between even
amongst Republican side between
campaigns one side is like so fully
transparent like they never once were
like all right let me see what you're
going to post let me see what you're
going to talk about here's are the
things you can talk about like literally
nothing they're like here's where
everyone's going to be hanging out here
here's a patch you can walk walk
everywhere you are and oh yeah here you
can meet Don Jr you can meet Eric Trump
you can meet Carrie Lake you can like
interview whoever you want like it's up
to you again free free roam and the
other side's like you can't walk in it's
so different on how you be treated you
know so that experience itself was just
so wild cuz I never thought in a million
years that I would be kicked out for
being
like independent and freee thinking and
just be associating and what happened
like to be guilty by association it's
such a weird thing and like it's
something that we all struggle with
these days that we are guilty because
we're friends with this person we are
guilty because we support this person we
are guilty because we believe in this
it's like the thing that's become
most it's something that we all think is
not right with the world right now right
ever since 20120 to now Guilty By
Association and for them to literally
practice that in real real life it was
just the oddest experience meatball Ron
is that what call meall R meatball
ronb the sanctimonious I think they just
call Meatball I don't know why they call
Meatball Ron yeah do you know why they
call him meatball Ron I I don't know
where the meatball Ron came from it's
catchy though but people also don't call
him Ron anymore they just call him Rob
or Rick or they
just um knowingly mispronounced his name
that was your smear campaign concept
earlier yeah we talked about that the
wrong name saying I thought it was uh
they they always said uh Trump said um
disan demonus disan demonus people R you
think you'll end up just being Biden
versus Trump yeah I mean it'll either be
Biden vers Trump that's exactly who it
is now anyone that thinks currently that
is just lying to you because no way
anyone other than Trump is on the right
right it's impossible the only way is if
they literally forcefully prevent him
through some weird unforeseen
circumstance right the other side is
definitely Joe Biden and the only way it
would be is if like right leading up to
the election time like look like there's
health issues he can't do it anymore and
he would potentially gracefully bow out
and then they would have to change some
election laws because like you're
supposed to be on the ballot by now they
would change some election laws because
you know like changing election laws
right before election is a thing now and
they would have to change some election
laws and most likely they would put in
someone like a Obama or Gavin duome wow
but even if they haven't been running
this whole time like shouldn't it be
like camalo or something I mean they're
supposed to be yeah like having a
Democratic primary and people should be
putting up their names up for a
potential candidate now people don't
know that there are actually two other
candidates running on the Democratic
side yep they are just not allowed on
the Democratic ballot so the DNC is not
allowing them to be on the Democratic
primary ballot in pretty much every
single State wow but they act actively
campaigning they actually Andrew Yang's
trying to promote one of the guys yeah
so there is Maran Williamson and Dean
Phillips I've never heard of any of
these people yeah no one's ever heard of
that's bad right I should know who they
are but they have like you're a bad guy
I'm bad guy they have like 5 to 8% of
the actual Democratic vote both of them
do so that would put them about the same
level as a VI Grandma Swami put them the
same level as a Ronda santis now put
them the same level as a Nikki Haley
like they actually have traction but
they're not allowed to be on the DNC
ballot which is crazy right because
they're always like Joe Biden is always
like Mega Republicans are going to steal
your democracy but then they don't allow
the Democratic process like why aren't
they allowed to be on bot why can't I
mean look at what they did to Bernie the
craziest yeah they snubbed them hard
because RFK was picking up traction and
I don't I'm not an RFK guy at all but he
should have been allowed to have his
voice you should have that's why he had
to run as independent even though it's
like a raspy voice right I mean I think
that's going to be his downfall because
imagine if you actually end up running
for president can you imagine the memes
vice president Macy
Gray do you think he actually has a
chance or no uh RFK cuz like we've never
seen an independent win but do you think
I don't I don't think he has a chance at
all really how come because you need to
be you need the support of the machine
like at some point you need the money
it's so expensive to run for president
number one number two the memes the his
voice is going to crush him because once
people start making all the funny clips
about him and he's got a really
checkered history and people don't talk
about now but that's definitely come
it'll smear it'll come out as a smear
like he has history of like you know
blatant drug use things like this that's
definitely a resurface people don't talk
about it now cuz he's actually not as
big and not a threat yet but that will
come out I don't think he survives that
but his but the but the story arc for
him is I I think the most interesting
about coming back and the Revenge story
about his father and his uncle and he's
going to come in and [__] dismantle
all the agencies I think I love that
story arc yeah do you think who do you
think would be the one to if they do did
need to run a smear you think it would
be coming from the Democratic side or
the Republican side I think both yeah I
I don't think I don't think the right
fears RFK at all because if you have RFK
I think Trump is is a bigger better
candidate he's got named brand value I
think if RFK were to run I think he run
into a problem because right now he's
like I represent the every man that's
kind of his thing people relate to him
but then once people realize he's
actually a Kennedy and being a Kennedy
means he's actually part of the biggest
royal royal political family in the
history of America it's like all right
he's actually not one of us he's
actually a part of the machine I think
that's going to become a narrative that
becomes hits a little bit harder like I
like a lot of of his ideas but they
haven't gone after him yet and once they
go after him I don't think he survives
it he's got too many skeletons in the
back in in the back so you just think
it's he might have his heart in the
right place but because of his
connection like he I don't think he
survived he just has a Target on his
back yeah yeah cuz right now it easy to
remove him because all they had to do
was kind of push him away from the
Democratic party and then force him
become Republican I mean to become
independent and once you become an
independent your campaign kind of goes
to die like how often you hear of RFK
anymore like almost never right um so I
think that's going to be the hardest
battle for him I don't think he has
enough legs to kind of push through I
just don't and it sucks because some of
his ideas I think are fresh and he's
willing to say some of the things that
people don't agree with but again once
he goes kind of bigger mainstream I
don't think he survives it yeah I think
um his voter base though will be more
similar to the Vivic and the trumps and
the and and if anyone from the left who
was like well I don't want to vote right
they would probably vote for RFK someone
who's more anti-establishment on the
left um but I don't really see another
candidate like that on the left that's
probably why he went independent Bernie
was the closest guy and and he's kind of
way too old now um yeah it's interesting
I I was watching this uh podcast with
Roger Stone he was uh Trump's campaign
manager he's been in politics for hella
years right stone is a chi yeah and and
so he was saying that if there is a a
candidate that's going to swap out with
Biden he thinks it's Michelle Obama or
uh call Calla first and and then they're
like wait you don't think he's going to
be Gavin Newsome and he goes well the D
the the Democratic party right now they
just can't like they can't have a white
man be president and put the uh the uh
like Michelle or K on the side like he's
going to have to run as Vice and I'm
like oh wow cuz he's like the play that
they do is like they'll be a hypocrite
and they'll be eaten up by their own
party so I was like wow that's
interesting yeah Gavin Nome is being
primed to be the 2028 candidate for sure
um he is if you're in California and you
don't like what he's done he is not
going away he will they are priming him
to be the 2028 candidate for sure and if
he has to be VP now then he'll probably
be 2032 right because hopefully they're
trying to do it that's Bart's favorite
guy by the way
that's the part that makes me so sad
because I'm like damn why are people so
[__] [__] like he [__] up San
Francisco already and then people like
we should make him
Governor well they try to recall him and
then they he [__] up California they
try to recall him no we definitely want
him now and they put him back in now he
[__] up California for a second time
like we definitely need him for
president I'm like what the [__] is
going On's promote him yeah you know how
people actually vote dude they go he
looks cool
like most people they don't [__]
think they don't read policy they don't
do any of that they look at a human
being and they go that man looks like a
leader he speaks well I like him who's
this old [__] uh who cares and Gavin
Nome is probably the best politician out
there cuz he's so good with his words he
is so polished he says a lot of nothing
he has a punchable face though dud he's
a guy he leads with one truth and then
follows up with 99 lies
so when you hear him you're like oh yeah
he just told something true and then he
takes you off guard and all of a sudden
it's just like lie Li the kids would
call that
RZ but he is phenomenal political yeah
political R he is so good at what he
does so I think that's someone that
people should be aware of about what's
going on and the Democratic Party Works
in a very different way than I think the
right the DNC especially the Democratic
National Committee they work they are
very party affiliated people so if the
DNC makes a decision everyone has to
follow the party line that's just how
they work right so it's top down if this
is what we tell everyone you have to
believe anyone that falls out of line of
what our narrative is they will crush
you and kick you out that's why it seems
like the Democrat Party is always kind
of speaking the same word and same
politics all the time because that's how
they operate you're not allowed to leave
the lines it's impossible M if you say
something that goes against the party we
will put you in Scandal and we will
remove you so everyone follows the rules
that's just how it is on the Republican
side they're a little more like that
they used to be like that also and then
this orange man showed up it's like no
I'm going to do it my way and people
like holy [__] now I what to do and that
just really disrupted the entire
Republican party because the people that
control the top of the Republican party
they hate Trump cuz they lost the
control they lost control well both
parties I heard used to operate that way
from Bush and pre previously the the
Republican party was the same as the
Democrat in the way they operated their
sponsors were the same it was completely
the the same way and and I heard that
well with Trump he's been a Democrat all
of his life but when he decided to run
for politics they did an analysis and
said you probably win on the right so he
kind of flipped and then started talking
to the people the same people that Obama
spoke to to win the working class
Americans which Hillary completely
forgot it when she did the campaign and
lost because it was all about her and
big city and and social snobs and I was
like damn that's crazy both guys Obama
and Trump one speaking to the average
human being in manufacturing and work
and and and and just like blue collared
work and stuff like that and I'm like
damn that's crazy how it works where
people are just looking at these
different even strategies of how to win
and and so what have you witnessed that
personally like watching it in the right
seeing how different camps operate yeah
I mean I when people think about Mega
right because that's like such a
polarizing word and people think that
people that associate with mega are just
taking Trump's talking points and
regurgitating them that's kind of what
people think right that Trump says
something everyone repeats it it's
actually the opposite people within in a
movement talk and talk about what in
their lives is bothering them what in
their lives that they see as
irregularities in the world and he's
listening to what people are talking
about and focusing on those issues so he
consumes like everything he knows
everything about everything going on in
the country what everyone is talking
about like that guy is a machine he just
consumes and he's like all right I get
it I understand and that's why people
resonate with him not because people are
thinking that he not because he's the
God and we're mimicking what he says
it's because it feels like there's only
one person out there at the top Echelon
of the world that's actually listening
to listening that's exactly what it is
and I think once people realize that
that the difference between left and the
right is like so small it's not like a
politics issue anymore it's not it just
isn't right it's that there is an
establishment in the world there is this
higher level of society
that wants to retain their way of life
and they want to control how we and the
bottom ason Society how we live our
lives to make it for their own agenda
for their own you know for their own
benefit and that the movement of people
is not a Left Right Movement it's a
movement of people going bro this [__]
up we're sick of this
[__] to the world like why do we have to
live like this it doesn't make any sense
I think that's really what the move is I
think more and more people understand
that and relate to that they get it yep
but a lot of people go you [__] Trump
supporter you [__] dumb woke liberal
and I'm all like it's not even about
that what it is is it's it's there's
this establishment group that's been in
power for a very long time and they've
been telling the people lies saying that
it's great for you and you guys should
all believe without question and it
doesn't matter if you vote right or left
but somehow as Andrew Tate and his fans
would say the Matrix has been [__]
exposed right so it's it's kind of funny
that we're seeing this whole uh blend of
reality and people looking at how
people's perspectives are so polar and
different because their reality is
getting disrupted if you grow up and
believe everything that school tells you
to you're going to be in a whirlwind of
[__] hurt I think it's one of those
things where if you see the crack in the
Matrix one time next time you see see it
a little bit more clearly and then you
see it a little more clearly and you
start questioning more and more and more
you're like [__] they've been lying to
me this entire time and once you see it
you can't unsee it and then it really
starts to make sense and that's the
scariest part because a lot of people
right now are waking up and it's hard
waking up to know that you've been lied
to your entire life it's like a scary
moment it's like being in the dark and
walking outside in the bright light for
the first time like [__] because your
entire world view is like shattered I
think that's why some people want to go
back in people that recall new something
like no no no like who's the next
candidate that seems even scarier to
pick someone else that I already don't
know at least I have some rapport with
this Nome guy let's just put him back in
yeah some it's just safety in the node
it's like in The Matrix I know the steak
isn't real but I want to eat it anyway
it's like the same thing you know
because there's comfort in what's
normalized to you and it's there's
comfort in giving up control so you
don't have to make those decisions for
yourself people don't want to be master
of their own life they don't because
what if you make a mistake everyone's
thinking what if what if what if what if
but if you are forced to be the master
of your own life that's a lot of
pressure so I think that's really where
people get stuck that's why I say dumb
asses need
communism but smart responsible moral
people they could be
libertarian